esta medida es en escencia para países
de suramérica áfrica y portugal todos
los ciudadanos británicos irlandeses y
residentes legales tendrá que pagar
estas mil 750 libras esterlinas o un
poco más de dos mil cuatrocientos
dólares por diez días de estadía en
estos hoteles seleccionados por el
gobierno para hacer las cuarentenas este
costo incluye además dos pruebas del
coronavirus y por supuesto alimentación
los primeros ciudadanos que fueron
llevados a estos hoteles para cuarentena
llegaron esta mañana al aeropuerto
internacional de heathrow el principal
de londres y uno de los más grandes de
europa la población que ha tenido que
iniciar esta cuarentena se ha quejado
por los altos precios y entretanto las
directivas del aeropuerto han dicho que
las personas que vengan de estos países
pueden experimentar cancelaciones de
vuelos o largas filas de más de cinco
horas en el aeropuerto ahora que el
reino unido ha cumplido su meta de
vacunar
15 millones de personas dar la primera
dosis de la vacuna a esta población la
más vulnerable y a los trabajadores del
sistema nacional de salud el gobierno
empieza a revisar las cifras para
levantar poco a poco este tercer
confinamiento en que está inglaterra
desde los primeros días de enero la
prioridad será volver a las escuelas a
partir posiblemente del 8 de marzo está
hoja de ruta que como se relajará un
poco el confinamiento será anunciado por
el primer ministro del próximo 22 de
marzo